ethiopia is expelling seven senior u.n
officials accusing them of meddling in
its internal affairs they include senior
figures with the un children's fund
unicef
and the office for the coordination of
humanitarian affairs they've been given
72 hours to leave this week the un
humanitarian chief criticized the
ethiopian government accusing it of
stopping much needed aid from reaching
the war-torn tigray region let's speak
to samuel gadachuk in addis ababa he's
an independent journalist good to have
you with us again samuel what is it that
these u.n officials are alleged to have
done
they are being accused by the ethiopian
government involving
themselves in the internal internal
issue of the country
and some of them are again accused of
doing things that the government terms
or sees as being
legal or unbecoming of a un official and
that's why they are being expelled
and i've have been told to leave the
country within 72 hours as of today this
of course comes after the humanitarian
chief criticized the ethiopian
government what are we to make of that
uh well you know the un agencies and the
ethiopian government side they haven't
been seeing
eye to an eye
they've been accusing each other of
different allegations going back and
forth the ethiopian side
has been saying that
they're all open to sending aid or
assisting the un sending or being able
to deliver aid to tigray the un has been
accusing the ethiopian side of uh
you know preventing them from delivering
aid so the allegation between them is
day and night it's black and white so
this was expected to come it's been
going on since day one how reliant upon
the u.n are people in the various
ethiopian regions how much of a blow
will this be to them
well you know usaid for example tweeted
a few weeks ago saying seven percent of
the ethiopian population are dependent
on aid that's supported by the us
uh ethiopia is a country in the move it
has one of the strongest economies but
it's still a nation that's dependent on
aid foreign aid so there are many many
people that rely on foreign aid
and the ethiopian government is yet to
explain how they're going to replace
this important u.n agencies that have
been
providing basic uh support for millions
of ethiopians but the ethiopian
government has insisted uh saying that
accusing the u.n of interfering and
affairs of ethiopia at one point they
are accused of supporting tpnf including
providing arms or transporting arms
and even donating or giving aid to their
soldiers so again the accusation has
been uh overwhelming and this was
expected to come all right
and one of them that's being deported is
the head of unicef ethiopia what would
it take to restore relations then uh
between ethiopia and the u.n
well that's best
to be answered by the leadership at the
u.n and ethiopia but
there has to be some kind of
understanding it's not the u.n agencies
that are being
removed from ethiopia it's just some of
the uh leading actors of the u.n that
has been leading uh in terms of giving
aid within ethiopia you know some of
them we know them as the face of the u.n
within ethiopia so um i mean this is um
while it's it was expected to come again
it's a shock
samuel good to talk to you again many
thanks indeed somebody will get at you
there in addis ababa
thank you